ادخل البنك الاوروبي لاعاده الاعمار
والتنميه ان تداعيات الاقتصاديه المحتمله
لزلزال القوي الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا قد تؤدي
لانخفاض بنسبه واحد في المئه في اجمالي
ناتج المحلي للبلاد خلال هذا العام تعادل
هذه النسبه حوالي تسعه مليارات دولار
قياسا لتقديرات رسميه لقيمه اجمالي الناتج
المحلي المتوقع ان تبلغ حوالي 867 مليار
دولار اضاف البنك ان هذا تقدير منطقي وفق
وصفه بسبب الدفعه المتوقعه من جهود اعاده
الاعمار في وقت لاحق من العام والذي سيعوض
التاثير السلبي على البنى التحتيه وسلاسل
الامداد وعدل البنك الاوروبي لاعاده
الاعمار والتنميه توقعاته للنمو في تركيا
اكبر مستقبل تمويله بالانخفاض لثلاثه في
المئه من ثلاثه ونصف في المياه في 2023 من
دون حساب تاثير الزلزال في هذه التقديرات
وفي تقديرات اخرى قال مصرف جيبي مورجان
الامريكي وان خسائر الاضرار المباشره التي
لحقت بالمنشاه في تركيا بسبب الزلزال قد
تصل الى حوالي اثنين ونصف في المياه من
اجمالي الناتج المحلي للبلاد اشار المصرف
الى ان تلك النسبه تعادل حوالي 25 مليار
دولار وتوقع ان يخفض البنك المركزي الطرقي
السعر الفائده بمقدار مئه نقطه اساس اخرى
في اجتماع الاسبوع المقبل الى ثمانيه في
المئه لم يستمع المزيد من الخفض في اسعار
الفائده قبل الانتخابات العامه المقرر
اجراءها منتصف العام الجاري